hey guys I want to go over some of the
differences when doing typescript and
react so to start off I like to use this
boilerplate called create react app
typescript it's very similar to create
react app but it is using typescript so
I'll link this in description below so
I'm gonna be using this as the starter
for today and here's what the code looks
like haven't touched anything but by
default they give you a nice TS config
with some good defaults and then we can
go in here and change any of these if we
want to and then also they have ATS
Flint which is nice as well which just
lets your typescript code so you have
both of those by default you don't even
have to worry about them so let's just
dig into some of the things that are
different so first off how you actually
import react so look at the top up here
I have import star as react from react
and the reason you have to do that is
because react does not export anything
by a default so now you'll import all
react like that and also when you're
installing other third-party libraries
you might have to do the same thing as
well it really it'll tell you when
you're doing it what you need to do
it'll have like little red lines like if
I get rid of that it's gonna be like hey
this has no default export this is what
the error looks like and that's how you
know you need to switch it over to this
alright the next thing is how do you add
basically types to your react components
so to demo this I'm going to create a
new thing I'm gonna call it form dot TX
TSX and you'll notice your file names
are different that's another thing so
instead of JSX it's tsx and I'm just
gonna copy these to make this faster
and don't eat those so this is going to
be a forum component and will impede
this out all right so first off this guy
might have props so what I like to do is
create an interface called props and
then here specify all the things that
you can pass to this component so maybe
this component has some text which is a
string and then maybe it also has a age
I don't know this just random value
which is a number and maybe that is
optional so the way you tell your
component is you do angle brackets at
the end here and then you pass in props
like that and now and I'm not sure what
it's mad at this is it likes to start
with I at the beginning of the interface
this is a TS lint thing so we can do it
like that if we wanted to
I usually turn that rule off though okay
so we have the props here so right off
the bat we'll get some nice auto
completion if we try like D structure
and our props so if I want to get like
text I can now render a div with text so
now we know we're gonna get this prompt
the other thing is state so
I might have for example a name which
will set as the people value just an
empty string and we'll also have an
email which is a string as well so
you'll you'll notice it's already not
liking stuff
oh it's sorting it doesn't like this
because looks like we haven't labeled it
public private or protected
I don't really usually mess with this
stuff we can label it private I guess
because we don't want anyone else to use
our state usually that rule I'll turn
off and TS lint as well and then let me
show you guys what I'm talking about
so what I'll usually do is when I don't
like some of these rules they're just
kind of annoying and they don't really
help me I'll copy them so member access
this thing in parentheses come over here
to TS lint and rules you paste it and
then you put a zero for you don't want
to follow it and then it'll no longer
bug you over here about it anymore and I
think I just gonna do false there we go
so now we no longer are bugged about
that and that's you can just turn them
off like that okay so the state we also
need to have a type 4 so again I like
create an interface called a state so
here we have an email which is a string
and a name which is a string and then
that is the second thing you add to the
angle brackets so comma by state and if
you don't have props what you can do is
you can just put an empty object and in
the state and then if you do not have a
state
you can just leave it like this and not
worry about it and we can also set our
state here like that so there we got eye
state and we specifically saying what it
is and then we can again we have now
there's some nice auto completion for
our state and it'll tell me the two
property is so named and maybe I'm
showing the name and the nice thing
about specifying the props on your
component is now if I'm over here I try
importing that so get rid of this junk
if I were to do our form and doesn't
look like it hey I wanted to just auto
import this guy for me maybe it's
because I didn't call it for him
no I did that's sad we'll just import it
ourselves and we don't need those two
okay so immediately we get red lines
because we've specified that we need to
have at least the prop text so that's
how we know and we can say hello and
then the red lines go away and if we try
added adding any other type of property
like maybe a is gonna be five it's not
gonna like it but I can't add for
example H which is optional so that's
the nice thing about specifying the
props on your component the other thing
here's just a common scenario is you'll
have like an input on it and let's say
that's my name and the value is going to
be name and on change just equal to this
dot
we'll change so this is if you want to
do a form and react so here we're
getting the this guy right here so this
is an event so we have to specify what
the heck is the type for this event
right well it's going to be react up
form of it and then you have to specify
the element so this is gonna be an HTML
input so this is a little bit weird but
this kind of stuff you can just google
whenever it comes up I'd use this one a
lot so I haven't memorized but you
expect this function here to give you
and I guess so just pops up now cuz we
added it here but it's gonna give us a
form event and this is coming from an
input element and the reason why I put
input element here is because this is
called an input if this was like for
example text area I would put HTML text
area element and then from that I can
say Const EDA target and then what I
usually like to do which is get the name
and value and then update the state with
those and with this one it doesn't pick
up on the types for whatever reason and
that's what it's complaining about here
so what I usually do is I just say any
so I don't have to worry about typing
those if I wanted to I could say name is
a string and value is a string
either way works well I guess name so ok
here's a little cute thing so now that
we have set the interface of state here
it knows that we can only have the keys
email a name so we can't just have a
generic name value here and what I mean
by that is it protects us so for example
right and what is it not like here oh
it's just not assignable I'm already but
we won't worry about that part for now
so to see how it's I have set stay here
we have named as one of the keys and
that's good but if I were to say name
too
it knows that name too is not in my
interface or in my state so I could not
actually add it so it protects you there
and checks the type of that but anyway
yeah that's why I just like to use any
because that really easily just like
fixes all the types because I know I
know what I'm using is correct the other
way you can get around that is like you
can get like the key of this interface
this is a trick I use sometimes so it's
name and we're gonna say it's a key of I
state so in value is the string okay it
didn't like it but the old trick where
key of is now a one of these things it's
either email or name but doesn't like it
I'm just gonna keep it back to any but
that's a little trick you can use in
other cases where you're working with
objects anyway so that's how you do
handle change if you're doing forms in
typescript the other thing I wanted to
talk about was importing libraries so a
lot of times you'll be importing
libraries that are not typescript
libraries for example I might want to
add blow - so let's say I just the yarn
add hello - here oh and I messed up my
node installation so I need to just add
this real quick and we're on this again
so when that is done we can now import
something from lo - right
below - and maybe I want to use the emit
guy the MIT function you in first off it
doesn't like that I have it ordered in
the wrong way again this is another rule
I like to just turn off let's come over
here and say false alright so I'm just
going to say omit from the props the
name not name age so this is just me
using omit just to be silly but the
point I want show you is look at this
little error we get could not find
declaration file so we don't have any
types for this lo - right now and
because it's written in JavaScript so we
don't know what the types of any of that
is so one way you can do is just say all
of them are anything and the way you do
that is by declaring the module so here
is images DTS so this is in this folder
you can see they're already declaring a
module so for some of these things we
could declare module lo - and now it
doesn't have any problems so now this is
gonna be typescript think slow - can be
the type of anything you can also
specify specifically what the types of
all the lodash things are and by the way
you can create other like I can create
my types all that matters is you have
the dot b dot t-- s at the end of it and
so i could move that over here as well
and you can declare your type in there
the other thing is what's nice is this
it's not very nice to have no types for
your libraries and other people need the
types as well so there's something
called definitely typed that adds types
for all these things so you don't have
to go and do this so we can just delete
that
so the way you do it is you say yarn add
and it's actually another package so at
types / flow - so this is a at the
beginning at types / and then the name
of the library now they don't always
have all the libraries but they have a
lot of them in this case they have low -
so now we have the types for low - and
it'll actually and we can hover over and
we can see actually what the type of
this omit function is so that's super
nice and I think that's about it when
working with react and typescript now
you'll probably run into some things
where you're using like higher-order
components and it can be really hard to
type them with that stuff I recommend
just Google and go to stack overflow for
that stuff it can get really complicated
or just using the any type with that
sort of thing and then yeah that's
pretty much it with libraries you might
have to be importing like this like with
react and then also remember to install
your types so here's my package so JSON
here are the types and you can see they
already install some types for you like
react and what these are is just type
declarations for typescript that someone
where you just went through and added
all the types for like low - yep that's
it for this video guys thanks for
watching